c'est un bâtiment d'enseignement
mutualisés comme son nom l'indiqué est
ce qui est mutualisé c'est le bâtiment
est un bâtiment qui va accueillir des
étudiants venant de six écoles qui
seront toutes présentes dans le quartier
de l'école polytechnique dans le cadre
du grand projet d'université paris
saclay l'idée c'était de créer un lieu
fédérateur
un lieu de rassemblement est un symbole
de ce rapprochement
le projet est située sur une parcelle
longue et étroite dont la façade s'ouvre
généreusement sur le green de michel
desvigne nous souhaitions ne pas avoir
une limite claire entre intérieur et
extérieur
donc c'est ainsi que la nature rentrer
généreusement dans le coeur du bâtiment
nous avons de plus un réseau de
passerelles et d'escaliers qui vient
liés
encore une fois extérieur et intérieur
le projet est aussi organisée sur un
plan très simple donc toutes les salles
de classe sont rejetés en arrière et
sont largement ouvertes sur ce coeur
ouvert de mener une réflexion sur
l'enseignement du futur qu'est ce que ça
veut dire de rassembler six écoles
qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'enseignés
aujourd'hui et demain
et de fait nous souhaitions privilégier
les espaces de rencontre et de partage
donc se résoudre de passerelles et
d'escaliers créé autant de lieux de
rencontres spontanées
ce projet est très importante pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que il
apporte une finition urbanistique au
campus de l'école polytechnique vers
l'ouest dans le futur grâce au projet
d'université paris saclay le l'entrée de
l'école se fera par l'ouest puisque la
gare du métro sera implanté dans le
quartier de danone de thales et
supoptique la deuxième raison pour
laquelle ce bâtiment est important c'est
que il est placé au contact de nos
laboratoires de recherche et qui va
recréer le lien entre l'enseignement et
la recherche est un lien très important
est la troisième raison c'est
effectivement le fait qui nous permet de
brasser dans un même espace les élèves
de six écoles qui sont des écoles qui
historiquement ont toujours travaillé
ensemble mais qui seront encore plus
unis dans le futur
c'est un réel défi parce qu'il s'agit de
donner un nouveau départ de données
nouvelle image cette université et
surtout pour nous c'était encore une
fois une réelle réflexion sur comment
répondre à ce sujet comment présenter
une vision pour le pool enseignants de
puisieux